there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magic when you slice that top
off and dunk that soldier into the yolk
[Music]
an anchovy soldier anchovies
interpersonal water no salt naturally
yeah anchovies are very salty so just a
touch of pepper
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being at
the seaside now get your soft butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 percent anchovy 5010
butter that way got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish i'm in heaven
the bread
this is a sourdough
delicious very crusty
take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell of the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil
the secret of softly boiling an egg is
to place them into the water gently on a
spoon
in
and just tilt so they don't hit the
bottom nice
and light
up to the boil count to five
turn the gas down
is it four and a half minutes is it five
minutes for a softball day i've cooked
thousands of them and every time
it's four and a half minutes whilst
that's boiling
get your bread
and spread that on there that is
incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
i'm sorry but i can't resist
oh my god
right
gas off
one
beauty in
two i feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
a fish becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes a cord
with us it just works sometimes these
dishes can become tired but a clever
twist helps make them fresh again
[Music]
like plum ones with the most amazing but
super simple beer baked bread hearty and
full of flavor
[Music]
salt is really important for bread it's
the first thing i do once i've cracked
it and smelt you want to smell that salt
baked throughout
beer in
about 250 mils of beer
[Music]
the reason why this recipe works so well
is it the beer it's got that yeast so
naturally it's gonna work beautifully
give that a really good mix i'm looking
for the mixture to be quite wet if the
dough becomes too firm then it's gonna
cook
dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
whisk that is perfect
beautiful
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and i quite like having my own little
loaf
give the moulds a really nice
lining with butter
make sure
you butter the top
now a tablespoon of flour dust inside
the mold
that will stop your mixture
sticking
tap out
any excess
three quarters fill your little molds
we're going to allow it to sort of rise
just so it comes above the mold and
forms this really nice miniature loaf
onto the tray a centimeter apart
into the oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180.
something quite nice about the smell of
home baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
red onion is a lot sweeter less harsh
than a white onion the
early days of
ones you've got those ghastly sharp
pickled onions that
make you almost cry when you're
crunching them i'm gonna lightly pickle
my
red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings a
little touch of salt a little sprinkle
of sugar and then a couple of cloves in
there that gives a really nice sort of
perfume and sort of makes the pickling
slightly more mellow
red wine vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red matches the red
onion so it goes hand in glove a couple
of tablespoons of vinegar
just give that a really good
mix
[Music]
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
worked their magic and it comes out with
a really nice light fragrant pickle
[Music]
[Music]
now generally
it's sort of three parts oil to one part
vinegar that's the sort of general
[Music]
base hmm
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern
approach to plan ones
[Music]
if i was making a watercress soup i'd
use the stalks but the stalks are a
little bit bitter so i just grabbed them
like that pinch them and then twist
[Music]
very peppery
very hot
but so juicy watercress in
your celery chop it nice and finely
it's the one thing that everybody leaves
is that stick of celery so
scatter it amongst the sellers
[Music]
before it comes out i'm going to glaze
the top with a little touch of milk that
will put a really nice finish to the
bread back in for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plain ones
generally you'll see it as a ham or
cheddar or stilton flour it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
[Music]
brilliant
peel some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar just get them dancing on
top
the dressing
drizzle ran in circles
and then finally
our delicious lightly pickled onions
give them a good squeeze
and look just dot the onions around
bread
it's ready
it's got that nice
yeasty smell
warm
crusty and delicious
there you go
that is my classic modern version
of a traditional stunning playerman's
wow
[Music]
to make the most out of my roast my main
course is the delicious stuffed roast
rib of beef
complete with tangy horseradish
yorkshire puddings
[Music]
but first i'm enlisting the help of my
eldest
15 year old megan to reinvent one of my
all-time favorite classic desserts eaton
mess bomb
right eat a mess what's the one thing
you love about is a mess i love the
meringues now this is a eaten mess
with a twist
what's the twist in it compared to the
normal one we're gonna freeze it so it's
almost like a sort of eaten mess bomb
wow now i'd like you to whisk the cream
please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be turned into
a coulis strawberries in first a little
dusting of icing sugar into the pan and
now the icing sugar will withdraw the
sweetness from the strawberries and
start caramelizing so let me show you a
nice quick way of whisking secret
whisking
is like 10 seconds on
and 10 seconds off
that way your arms don't get tired
now
i'm going to take the cream to a
three-quarter stage what is a
three-quarter mix so we leave some sort
of texture in the cream and that's what
we call
three-quarter whip
you've got a nice
soft peak
they're caramelized there you go we'll
put a little touch of water in there
that'll help
break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine i'm
gonna blend it
on
and blitz
off
okay that's fine i want you to use the
back of the spoon
and push that
through the sieve okay now that way you
don't get those seeds it smells so good
i love this now nice this is the
exciting part wow hold up oh mag
megan
right now the meringue with your fingers
just crush and flake the meringue into
the cream how big should i crush it dado
there
nice big chunks
okay lovely
oh you okay yeah got me wrangling my eye
damn
to make this dessert even easier i often
cheat by using good quality shop port
meringues a little taste that's just
cream and meringue
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple of spoons
of the cooling
now look at that now
to prepare the mold to transform the
traditional eaten mess into a frozen
bomb form a triple layer of clim film
adding water to the bowl will help the
cling film stick
as i pour that in i want you to spread
it down okay at the bottom and push it
down can you hear that crunch yeah the
line all right
now
fold the cling film over
put that in the freezer please
make young please
in the freezer she goes
[Music]
dessert done now for our main course
with a twist that is the rib eye we've
had that in the fridge not wrapped so it
sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor gross so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and i are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with the spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
let's do it with a salt and pepper
please
here we go
some of your left shoulder some left
shoulder thank you
in with the garlic and the mushrooms to
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
push it down
and flip very good that's it push down
nicely that was lovely and again
nice i'm gonna drop let's see well done
well done well then right we're gonna
sort of make a little well a little
touch of butter in the middle
now we need to start putting the spinach
in the middle piece
so you can push that down the spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan
toss it and you'll see it wilting
and disintegrating away wow who would
have thought all that spinach could fit
in this pan because it's a very delicate
leaf it sort of cooks so quickly put
this all on your board now
and then i just want you to go
and give that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely
good
now outside and come in gently
good
regroup
and take your time
yes
mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you pour
down you sort of strip
lemon thyme in now tarragon it'll taste
brilliant with the beef
fantastic with chicken and fish roughly
chop the tarragon and i sprinkle the
fresh breadcrumbs so the breadcrumbs
almost sort of bring the stuffing
together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk
now with the beef this is the exciting
part
slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt
and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold out there like that
okay
yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens the stuffing will come out
that's right
that's ready for roasting but we're
going to protect it and sit it on a
trivet
so trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil mix
that in
i'm gonna pour my mustard powder over
the beef so this forms a really nice
glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm going to lace mine
with fresh horseradish
[Music]
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk all
the lumps out
and if like me you like your puddings a
little lighter and crispier add a
dribble of cold water and add salt to
season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven
that is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest how long
would you say to rest it for um i like
to rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but
vegetable all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up and
turn a delicious golden brown
with the yorkshire puddings on the way
and the beef rested we can finish off
the eater mess bomb run the bowl
under the hot water
twist
and pull
nice wow look at that beauty
it's amazing sit that
on
to your plate
now the finishing touches a drizzle of
the remaining strawberry coulis i'm just
going to pour this over amazing flavor
and some grated mint chocolate
and that is a nice twist
on a classic eaten mess a delicious eat
and mess bomb
beautiful let's go baby
please don't drop that baby meg please
it's not around as much
dessert sorted and the beef is ready to
serve up lift that up place that onto
the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in half they've got all that flavor
one beautiful big slice
for daddy
one for maggie and then on the side it's
stuffing the stuffing a bit that's the
best to die for
now fantastic yorkshire amazingly
beautiful mm-hmm that's for my daddy
and that one that's for me
beautiful roast beef
with a twist
wow
[Music]
these are my ultimate classics with a
twist juicy river beef with horseradish
spiked yorkshire puds
and scrummy eaten mess bomb topped with
strawberry coulis and mint chocolate
you